[Music]
all right what's up guys I am back with
another cooking video different.i we've
been so busy lately from working on a TV
show pilot to working on podcasts just
working on a podcast I've got a less
stuff going on anyways it is holidays
for coming up and I thought why not make
a cooking video holidays always make me
want to make food because it's Tallaght
for me growing up there's always lots of
food being made and my mom just like
making Chinese food so I've decided to
make a dish that my mom used to make for
Thanksgiving a lot and that is Canton
styled braised duck now duck it happens
to be one of my favorite birds to eat
definitely a lot better than turkey I
think it's a little too dry for me and
duck is on the opposite end of the
spectrum where it is duck has a very
thick layer of fat in the skin and so
it's very thick and it renders really
well into the meat and stays really
juicy and this dish is not to be
confused with the Peking duck Peking
duck is a roasted duck this dish however
we're gonna submerge it into a braising
liquid it's a fast recipe considering
it's a whole duck and it's one of those
dishes where it's so aromatic it fills
your house with this beautiful wonderful
smell the type of smell that brings me
back home to my childhood and I can't
wait they've never had duck and you're
gonna try duck for the first time give
this recipe a go
and let me know what you think alright
so first up you get your duck most Ducks
that I've come across are always frozen
the safest way to defrost the duck is to
keep it in the fridge and let it defrost
slowly in the fridge rather than keeping
it out now when you open your duck it's
gonna have a lot of gizzards and hearts
and organs liver what else the neck of
the duck I like to pack all the innards
inside a plastic baggie for a later
usage if I decide to use it because I
don't always use it in fact I most of
the times I pack it in a plastic baggie
and then I just end up tossing away a
couple days later because I realize I'm
never gonna get to it alright so it's
always good to wash your duck before you
get started
once you have been washed put it on the
cutting board and there's just flat the
skin that I always find annoying so I
chopped off that skin that's where the
neck is supposed to be I guess and then
from there I like to hit the duck with
some salt and pepper front and back and
rub it in is the first thing we're gonna
do is bring in a sear the duck on the
outside gently place it into the wok now
the beautiful thing about this recipe is
that it's a one pot recipe well there's
a roasting thing afterwards to help to
get into later but for the most part
you're doing most of the work in one pot
and by a pot I mean wok and the best
thing about a wok is that it acts kind
of like a pan and a pond at the same
time so pretty cool invention out say
I'll walk is so we lower the duck into
the wok no oil needed because the duck
has so much fat that it's gonna render
the fat out and it's gonna be basically
frying pan frying in its own grease you
basically just want to pan fry it both
sides of the duck just to brown up on
both sides and what you want to do is
just crisp up the skin all right so then
once you've got your duck seared on both
sides go ahead and remove the duck from
the heat put it in a baking dish and
you're gonna see that there's a lot a
lot of lot of oil inside the wok so
we're gonna discard the oil and the
beautiful thing about all this oil that
you get I actually like to save the oil
and I love saving this this rendered fat
because duck fat has a very unique
flavor and it just gives you a lot of
different possibilities when in terms of
using this rendered fat for other dishes
all right so now onto cooking our
aromatics
what we're gonna do now is take one
tablespoon of that duck fat put it back
into the wok we're gonna toss in our
ginger and garlic the point essential
ingredients in Chinese cooking in my
and almost everything extra fry
everything begins with ginger and garlic
so we're gonna have five sizes of ginger
and six cloves of garlic I'm gonna toss
that into the oil and we're gonna stir
fry that saute it and really sweat the
flavors out and infused into the oil
we're gonna add one tablespoon of sugar
and we're gonna melt the sugar into the
oil next we're gonna be adding the
liquids to the wok and this will be the
beginning of our braising liquid so
we're looking at light soy sauce dark
soy sauce and Chinese rice wine these
three will be the foundation of the
coloring and the flavor of the sauce
Chinese rice wine has a very floral
essence to it the way it smells the way
it tastes and we'll need about 1/2 a cup
of Chinese rice wine after that add a
quarter cup of light soy sauce and after
that add one and a half tablespoons of
dark soy sauce and that's gonna give
thick the hue the color of this dish to
balance out the savoriness and the sweet
in the floral miss we're also going to
add three tablespoons of vinegar just
regular vinegar adding just a slight
amount of tang to it and now we're gonna
start introducing our dry ingredients
our herbs in this bowl I got some star
anis some cloves and some bay leaves now
the star needs I have it is near the
bottom of the bag and so I have all the
broken pieces now pretty sure it grabbed
about three star aneesa's worth of star
anis crumbs in this mix I also have six
cloves and three bay leaves we're gonna
plop all that stuff in there mix it
around and it's in the starch mode real
good every time a cuckoo star nice Isaac
over
I'm making fun at home because he loves
but and Star News is a big part of the
Fabri it's like that unique cinnamon
flavor so because of the star news I
know Isaac will like this dish too
alright so now that we got all our
ingredients mixed in you might be
wondering well this is a really salt and
dish there's a lot of soy sauce in there
while you're right it's gonna be very
salty if you don't add some water to it
so it's very strong flavors at this
point we're gonna tame that flavor a
little bit with some water and we're
gonna add about 3 cups of water and this
would also raise the braising liquid sup
high enough so that we can submerge our
bird we bring up the braising liquid to
a boil and we carefully lower the bird
back into the wok now it's a full wok
full of boiling liquids so be careful
don't just pop it in there I've done
that before and it's not very fun now I
always like to put the breast side down
first because it's the thickest portion
of the duck in terms of needing to cook
through the duck so I put the breast
side down first and turn the heat down
to low and let it simmer now you want to
cook this dish for a total about 45 to
50 minutes that works out to about 2 to
3 flips every 15 minutes so after every
15 minutes we're gonna go back we're
gonna flip it and we're gonna expose the
back of the duck to the braising liquids
breast side up and after another 15
minutes of that flip back around breast
side down again I'm just back and forth
up until about the 4550 minute mark and
this already depends on the size of your
duck I guess if you have a huge-mongous
dog maybe even go for a full hour all
right so now the duck is done with the
braising process we're gonna go ahead
and set up that baking dish that we had
earlier with the duck we're gonna put a
rack inside the baking dish so we can't
elevate the duck from being sitting in
its own juices now it's time to work on
the glaze
now the glaze is it's very simple
nothing fancy it's literally one part
honey one part water one tablespoon of
water
microwave it get it to be hot and then I
like to add my tablespoon of honey and
then because of the heat of the water
obviously the honey is gonna melt easily
into the water mix it up whisk it
together and voila you got your honey
glaze very very simple stuff and what
we're gonna do with this honey glaze is
gonna we're gonna just
on top of the skin so then we can have
some sugar on the outside of the skin
someone would kindly do the last part
which is roasting the duck the sugar in
the honey will help char the skin which
then creates a nice outside texture for
the skin and it's gonna be you
and once the duck is done being glazed
we are going to put it in the oven the
oven should be set at 425 degrees
Fahrenheit we want it relatively high so
a catch are the skin of the duck and
we're gonna roast it for about 15 to 20
minutes or until the skin is crispy to
your liking and once you're done
crisping the skin go ahead and pull it
out and let the duck rest for 10 minutes
and let all the juices redistribute into
the muscles and into the meat of the
duck and the next part is the best part
serving time now you can always serve
this as with some rice or inside of
noodles generally I like to put this
with rice but sometimes I just like the
caveman it too and just eat it as is all
right moment of truth guys duck sauce
[Music]
conversion and duck is hugely underrated
in my opinion no one ever talks about
duck holiday seasons it's always turkey
I'm tell you though duck is where it's
at it is a fan of your bird but because
of the fat it's also a juicier bird this
is a nice nostalgic meal right here
the aroma in my kitchen the flavors in
my mouth it was part of my childhood
right here yeah I hope you guys enjoyed
this cooking video I if you never had
duck before again give it a try let me
know what you think I'm gonna start
making these cooking videos more often
again I really haven't been doing a good
job with making cooking videos on the
regular but moving forward into the new
year I'm gonna try and make more cooking
videos and feel free to let me know what
you want to see me make and I look
forward to seeing your comments down
below
[Music]
[Music]